it's another day and night of protests
over the killing of George Floyd
remained mostly peaceful thousands
marched in major cities across America
from Boston to Memphis to Los Angeles
there were some arrests mostly for
violating curfew hundreds of protestors
blocked a bridge in Portland Oregon last
night laying down with their hands
behind their backs Anthony in in Floyd's
hometown of Houston a protester and a
police commander hugged and took a knee
recognizing each other as equals
tens of thousands showed up for a march
in Floyd's honor protests in Washington
DC lasted into the night with some
people throwing fireworks and water
bottles at troops and other law
enforcement officers working with police
they responded with pepper spray from
behind a newly constructed fence that
enlarges the White House security
perimeter
US Representative Ayanna Presley is
calling for all levels of government to
adopt new policies and reforms the
Massachusetts Democrat introduced a
resolution in the house to condemn
police brutality and racial profiling
and she joins us now from Boston
congresswoman good morning it's been
very interesting in the aftermath of
George Floyd's death to see people on
both sides of the political aisle say
they condemned the killing but then
they're not very specific about what
needs to happen next
you are being specific so what is your
vision for police reform well first let
me be clear and say the reason why I
think it's important that a
congressional resolution is brought to
the floor and voted on is because
congressional intent is a powerful tool
and we are in the Democratic majority we
have the most diverse and representative
Congress in the history of Congress and
we should act like it and in this moment
Congress must function as the conscience
for our nation and that is why I've
introduced a resolution in partnership
with our the chair of the Congressional
Black Caucus Karen bass and
representative Omar denouncing police
brutality racial profiling and excessive
force we use congressional resolutions
to set a value sprayin when it comes to
foreign policy the last time
Lucian like this was introduced was in
1999 by representative Danny Davis it
never made it to the floor and I cannot
begin to approximate the number of black
lives that have been lynched brutalized
murdered surveyed profiled from 1999 to
now there is unrest everywhere and it
will persist for as long as there is
unrest and so this congressional
resolution at this tipping point moment
is an important affirmation and then we
have many bills in the queue that the
Congressional Black Caucus will be
rolling out that get us to those broader
reforms do you think congresswoman that
there is agreement on this idea of a
tipping point it's been interesting to
hear the president's national security
advisors say there is not racism in
policing in this country I talked to the
chief of the NYPD here in New York City
he does not believe there is a systemic
problem is that just a difference in
vocabulary or a fundamental difference
in vision it's a fundamental difference
in many things and I really don't have
much patience for care what Donald Trump
and or anyone a part of his corrupt
administration who codifies their
cruelty and their bigotry in policy
every day depending on the moment Donald
Trump has been either a hapless
bystander or an insider of violence
someone who refers to my community as
the blacks is not anyone who I am
listening to at this moment he is
completely calloused disconnected and
removed from the hurt and the trauma the
generational hurt and trauma as a black
woman married to a black man raising a
black child I would very much like to
pass on to my 11 year old daughter
something other than generational trauma
and to be clear the unrest that is
happening the peaceful protesting and
demonstrating is not only about police
brutality bear in mind the black
community is disproportionately bore the
brunt of koban 19 we are managing that
trauma and that loss a pandemic within a
pandemic a public health pandemic and
the scurbs that is police brutality
layered with the true
of housing injustice economic injustice
education injustice and healthcare
injustice James Baldwin said not
everything that his face can be changed
but nothing can be changed until it is
faced and as a nation we must face our
failure in this moment we have
legislated hate and hurt it is
disproportionately been put on black
folks and we must now legislate healing
and justice yeah well when we talk about
healing it tends to imply a some sort of
a coming together when you think about
the nation as a whole how do we come
together when it seems there are so many
different stories about what America is
right now there's a story that you're
telling and then there are the voters
for the president for many of your
opponents on the other side of the aisle
in Congress and they don't recognize the
America that you're describing so how do
you bridge that divide because the only
way you're gonna get anything passed of
course is if everybody votes as a
majority but that's why what is
happening the organizing and to be clear
community organizers the people that I
was with in community and our black
lives matter local protest last night
community organizers are community
builders not destroyers the only thing
we seek to destroy or dismantle is
structural racism and systemic
oppression and so public pressure is
important it holds us accountable the
reason why we have often acted with
conviction as lawmakers is because of
the courage of everyday people the civil
rights movement we're still in it it's
not over but early freedom writers like
John Lewis who I have the honor of
serving with they gave us the blueprint
organized mobilized legislate now we'll
pretend that it's hard to be encouraged
given this gop-led Senate which just
yesterday was voting on lifetime
appointments another Trump
lifetime appointment instead of bringing
real relief to the American people in
the midst of the pandemic and passing
the heroes Act instead of acknowledging
the scourge that is police brutality and
racism but Congress this is
Gustav body and institution one that
I've been connected with for 20-plus
years I'm new to Congress as a member
but I've been associated with this body
for decades as an intern as an aide and
I have tremendous respect for this body
and my colleagues we have denounced evil
many times before and we should do it
now
so congresswoman given that we're in a
situation nationally where we're roughly
half the population probably doesn't
agree with you could be more than half
the population how hopeful are you that
change will come in the wake of George
Floyd's killing and be lasting change
comes when we organize for it when we
mobilize for it and when we demand it
and you know so far as you're wondering
how many people agree with me when I'm
in community we were with thousands of
people yesterday from every walk of life
and I just want to take a moment to
acknowledge the youth leadership that we
continue to see on the front lines of
this movement this movement will not be
co-opted we will be sustained we will be
vigilant and we will be precise in our
demands because the legislation that has
been put upon black folks codifying hurt
and trauma for generations was very
precise and very targeted so in this
moment we too must be precise we must be
focused and so I am very hopeful all
right we can end on a hopeful note then
at least for a moment anyway a
representative Presley I appreciate your
time this morning and hope you have
thank you much
thank you very much congresswoman